the first thing in the morning you guys are so chatty
oh so noisy in the classroom so noisy
Reflens Reflens shit steady on steady on what's going on here
oh you guys are so loud in the background
well well well well okay okay settle down settle down settle down settle down
oh okay pause.mp3 okay there we go Reflens that's what i'd like to see now there'll be a few
notes in my class before we get to the edumication stage okay we're just gonna go through them
together rules of my class you must remain seated at all times please do not get out of your chair
as i do my presentation Reflens that is disrespectful to your teacher miss cuttles as well as disrespectful
to your fellow students okay i just realized i forgot to download a pointer png add it on teacher
pointer png i knew i forgot something i got i knew i forgot something teacher pointer png stick
stick png surely surely there's gonna be a png on here surely it's not gonna be a .mp3
it's a fucking jpeg why is it always a jpeg are you a pointer stick no you're a fake jpeg hold on
i'm getting there you know what i'm typing in spaghetti .png surely there's a no not an actual
spaghetti dish this is terrible i don't know what to point with can i point with a reflin i'm so sorry
i only have a png of a refling at the moment you're gonna have to forgive me i'm sorry reflin
i'm gonna have to use you as a pointer oh i'll use your tinfoil hat as a pointer because that's
literally the only point i have i'm so sorry it's so scuffed hold on okay there we go i will use
the tip of your head as my pointer okay thank you for volunteering and coming to the front of the
class refling don't be shy and you come up you come okay so everyone must remain seated at all
time do not ask to use the toilet and license in emergency i only have one hall pass okay because
apparently hall passes are a thing in america and you're not allowed to go can i graduate early no
you need to do favors um if you think you are graduating this class without kissing my cock
you are dead wrong um okay there's only one hall pass so you're not all allowed to go to the hall
pass at the same time okay all water bottles are to go on the floor i hope you brought a water
ball you're gonna need it for them and education i'm about to give you today i already have my
cup of tea oh you hear that i'd say good morning good evening good afternoon but we're kind of
only doing you know if we're doing school it's technically good morning for good morning
well okay you can take notes at any point during my lecture but remember there's gonna be polls
via youtube chat so you need to if you want to answer there's gonna be a few polls okay
okay and then remember to sign your name at the top of the piece of paper reeflings you know who
you are you always forget to do it it's literally the first thing i've been hammering into you for
months now for months i have been trying my gosh darn diddly horridest for you to remember to put
your name at the top of the paper you're old enough reefling come on now it's the one thing i can't
keep identifying your work via your handwriting reefling okay okay now i've completely lost the
scene of where the next slide is hold on let me find it school is in there we go i've got it
it's got it's called school is in okay now in america if you didn't know americans have to
razz for the national anthem so i everyone please stand okay i'm unironically standing right now
chair shuffle dot mp3 that's because i'm standing up now please place your hand over your heart
because i think that's what americans do instead of i pledge allegiance we're doing the reefling
velour coulda conduct this is totally not why i asked her on twitter yesterday
okay our mummy and velour horny be her name her kingdom come her bidding will be done did you
forget that part on youtube as it is on patreon give us this our daily nut and forgive us our cringe
as we forgive those who cringe against us and lead us not into celibacy but instead deliver us
into temptation amen beautiful right sit by down sit by down fantastic thank you thank you fantastic
participation okay that was beautiful thank you for doing our national anthem right let's get into
the education let me let me take a sipping tin of my tea topic one ovulation now a little reefling
i'm gonna need you to point a little around for me so the first topic's ovulation and then we've
got a little yeah that's how you know i'm a cool teacher okay that's how you know i'm a cool teacher
because i've got little emojis and stuff in the in the the presentation okay so there are no silly
answers reeflings just uneducated ones okay we are in the digital age of information so let us learn
together all right i have the very first poll for you now don't be embarrassed if you get anything
wrong that's not how any of this works it's not how any of it works okay let's do a poll you're
just to guess okay start a poll now the question is how many days in a month is a woman fertile
so how many how many days in a month can she get pregnant okay again there's no wrong questions
just there's no wrong answers um just uneducated ones and it's not your fault if you're uneducated
in anything the school system is not set up for the most successful if you're any sort of way
so please feel free to use the chat how often sorry how often how many days in a month do you
think a woman is fertile please again there is no wrong answers just uneducated ones okay
just uneducated one do not be embarrassed if you get anything wrong who said oh we've got a question
thank you for raising your hand are the three holes real um yes it is uh there's the p-hole the urea
there is the um vaginal entrance hole and then there is the anus for release of stool yes that's
a good question thank you thank you okay we're just getting some some of the results back some of
the results back okay we're going to end the poll results thank you everyone for participating in
that poll i am about to blow your mind little reeflings because c is actually not correct no a
woman is not fertile uh as soon as as soon as a woman experiences um periods no she's not
fertile at all moments but the next uh voted result b is seven days in a month she is fertile no
reeflings no a woman technically at a maximum per month at 48 days has a chance to get pregnant
now where do we even start with the reproductive system of a woman it is insanity no no please
don't worry please do not worry at all i will be taking any brian not now i'm teaching i will
respond to anything at the end of the uh the lecture thank you please do not blurt out in the middle
of class about your uh deadlift bench press thank you thank you reeflings keep it to yourself
also and reply after soon so technically during the monthly cycle of a woman okay there you know
when when a woman goes oh i'm ovulating you know how she can tell a certain type of slain
evacuates okay that's how a woman can tell she's ovulating she can only get pregnant
now i've been i've been very generous to say two days because on a technicality yes but the actual
egg that is ready to be fertilized before it falls too far from the fallopian tube down into the
the womb area 20 you've pretty much got 24 hours so you know when people say it's really hard to
conceive and they've been at it for ages because they're looking for the tiniest slither of a window
okay and and there's a bit of a misconception that the first time you ever have coyotes that
you cannot get pregnant this is a misconception please do not be embarrassed if you thought
these things the reason i am bringing it up is because that's what people think and i want to
discuss it and um you know give you so you can get pregnant the very first time uh you quote you
have quite us um but um the reason why i'm giving you a two-day time frame to impregnate your uh
consenting adult is because sperm can stay alive in the womb for over five days so in theory
you could do the dance with someone okay and they are they're not in their fertile period
so they cannot get pregnant but then the egg moves into position causing them the ability
to get fertile from your few-day old sperm conception is an absolute miracle even happens
in the first place it is a fantastically uh unique thing um so again so this is the tight
clam syndrome one point to here and then this is where the cervix begins and the eggs come from
this ovary and it gets grabbed and it goes down the fallopian tube and into the cervix and if
if you're lucky so this is you many years ago however old you are this is you right now because
you were the first one to reach the egg so the first person to reach the egg wins everyone else
dies perishes and fire and no um and then there you go so this is where the tight clam entrance
is and then there's a little um length chamber now in hand you don't actually access the inner
cervix this would be incredibly painful you do not access this area but the sperm you
access the area and they swim up and then they touch the egg and then it's you it's fantastic
so yeah uh you've got 24 you're 24 hours to impregnate a woman monthly that is why when
people say they have a one-night stand and then a baby is the result of that oh my god you're so
unlucky that's really terrible but it was your choice not to wrap it so consequences of your
actions you know how it is okay next topic dun dun dun dun dun dun dun seeds glorious seeds
right i'm gonna drink my tea before it gets cold we're doing seeds take a look at the photo these
are my real seed collections as you can see you have a lot of samples drying before i put them away
in jars um oh we have a question thank you for raising your hand refilling is that a drawing
of your specific one no mine is a lot different mine is tilted it is a lot skinny milinky skinnier
and it really hurts so okay let me finish my tea you're not a teacher if you don't have a cup of
tea so i mean myself i'm okay okay you're not a real teacher if you don't like slurp the absolute
shit out of your tea are you ready for the slurpage are you ready
yeah literally why is it teacher slurps so loudly like yeah damn i thought i slurped loudly but
teachers are on some other level you can as long as you raise your hand uh you're feel feel free to
interrupt and ask a question as long as you raise your hand okay tilted yes uh just like the fortnight
tilted towers apparently my cervix is tilted so uh i'm extra good for doggie style let's go
hmm how is it tilted i just spawned in like that it's like why is your left one bigger than your
right one look i don't come at you and say stuff about your ball sack please do not come for my
tilted cervix i'd appreciate that this is ridiculous honestly
you're making me want a cup of tea again straight oh you got oh reefling got me an apple delicious
thank you i will have that apple at break you're such a teacher's pet there you go good reefling
okay our first uh our next question again remember do not be embarrassed
uh oh shit i can only have four options thank you nissa did alpha bravo charlie
uh the question i would like to ask you and again don't be afraid to be wrong don't there's nothing
wrong with being wrong you'll be shocked at how many things i'm wrong with and say it with full confidence
disperse my question for you is how many ways can seeds disperse this is our next topic seed
now it is unrelated to the previous topic but ovulation and impregnation uh i mean actual
seeds that come from plants and stuff now please don't be afraid to tell me how many types of
seed dispersal do you think there are well oh you need oh you've got a reason can we see your
serve it no okay next good will you the fact that you're is a part of the test will note it down
regardless that's hilarious i'll just give you more than the apple okay let's see what we say
we're saying there are four types is what the majority is saying oh we should have played
fucking cahoots you know that the cahoots have ip i will fucking make another stream like this
of cahoots doesn't have ip showing um yeah okay end poludes so the reeflings collectively decided
there's four types of seed dispersal that's curious okay can anyone please raise your hands
but can anyone tell me any type of seed dispersal because there are five types of speed seed
dispersal now if i've done this correctly i should actually have a certain there we go five types
can anyone in the class name any type of seed dispersal um or any type of example of a seed
dispersal please go on wow i missed a poll see that's what happens if you don't stay awake during
my class young man you need to wake up it's first thing in the morning you're being forced to be
educated um oh someone said explosion well done explosion is ballistics well done reefling
someone said spores now spores is related to mushroom very good answer not quite correct
but mushrooms aren't seeding seeding type of um thing so very good uh call out though don't worry
wind wind dispersal fantastic we have ballistic and wind someone says air i guess wind air
absolutely same someone says animal fantastic please remember to raise your hand if you are
shouting out it's hard to hear you all at once please do raise your hand fantastic now i'm looking
for two more we have animals ballistic and wind i'm looking for two more answers i'm trying to hear
it oh i'm looking i'm looking uh put dispersal that goes under animal very good very good
we have water dispersal fantastic that's four out of five there's one more type of dispersal
we have yet to unlock we have animal water ballistic wind don't worry pollination from insects
and animals now you're going you're going steps ahead you're going steps ahead so pollination is
how the seed is created the ovum and stem from the flowers come together oh we have falling fruits
well done we have discovered all five kinds of seed dispersal fantastic reeflings the delay is
20 seconds is it are you being for real right now why the fuck is it the least 30 seconds hold on
pause the role play is the dis is it 20 why is it 20 seconds are you serious setting
hold on hold on can i change this live or is it not gonna let me do it live
dinner karmia
why is it not ultra oh my god i can't change it because we're in the middle of a freaking stream
are you serious i can't change it midstream you're right we are on a 22nd delay why are we on a
22nd delay it's never been a 22nd delay before oh for goodness sake okay well anyway fantastic work
yes that is the five kinds of seed dispersal so gravity can be a type of a i think it's a sycamore
plant is that twirly one that comes down i'm so sorry i apologize i i don't know why it's not
on reactive wind example is a dandelion okay okay ballistic is an okra okra i probably
saying it horrifically wrong but basically it shoots out and it goes like okay and then water
is coconut did you know coconuts float and they were perfect for floating in the ocean
and coconuts are very unique thing i could probably go into a big massive rant about the
uniqueness of seeds and plants that's for another day and then an example of animals
dispersing seeds is an apple you eat the apple you eat the seed and then it's fantastic everyone's
having a good time thank you thank you and then this is my actual seed collection um i pick up seeds
on a wild walk i just go on a walk i grab seeds i have i'm gonna confess here um i have gone into
people's gardens just to grab seeds off of their plants and then run off their property again
but like these ones for example are drying out you must have a dry seed sample before you put
them away in these test tube thing uh little tube things or um you risk actually getting mold and
stuff like you can see this these tiny little black specks those are the seeds that's how tiny
they are in that sample but you can see the stain that the fruit um like the innards of the dispersal
method was i was actually uh i really enjoy seed collection uh unfortunately it's winter so there's
like nothing to collect right now um but that's safe this this seed band it look i don't only
steal seeds from flowers okay i steal your seed as well well i'm at it relax i'm doing
i'm molly tasking right back to school boom next topic region locked capitalism also known as
feudalism now let's just take a yes have you again i'm a cool lecturer so here's the king of the land
it goes it's free real estate and then it's michael from vsauce and then it goes or is it
vsauce theme plays boom boom now feudalism occurred within the ninth ninth century ninth yes
ninth century to the 15th century fantastic stuff it lasted a very long time so first
reef links i would like you to imagine not having full access to the world map okay the reason
for this is because the globe was the globe was unlockable however um the humanity did not put
enough perk points into transportation yet to unlock globalism so we weren't at that stage we
were region locked capitalism which is called feudalism okay um so feudalism is the dominant
social system in medieval europe okay where the disgusting nasty disease ridden peasants us were
forced into labor on farms right but in the exchange of this labor uh oh let me just read
how the the how it's phrased online we're obligated we're obliged to live on the lord's land and give
him homage labor and share of the produce notionally in exchange for military protection okay because
people used to pillage and stuff back in them times right and nay one once shanked everyone was
minding their own business nay one once shanks but you don't like the stories and nights nights
are real okay nights are actually a thing that happened okay so if we look at our beloved pyramid
um of region locked capitalism um we are the peasants and the serfs we are down here this is
us down here we would be telling the soil in the fields producing all of the food um what did i walk
into i'm becoming a teacher um so we made all the food in exchange that we could have basically
have board and protection from being shanked okay okay um so there's craftsmen there was farmers
and merchants now those were above us that's what we were trying to obtain to be it was not possible
to spawn it it was so hard if you were a peasant and to spawn in and then to become a knight or a
battle but with any form of shitty capitalism there's always a high table and the high table
tier begins at the nobles and the monarchs and then the pope and the church they are all high tier
table and above do not be mistaken okay you ate your homework what do you mean you ate your homework
i've not even given you your homework yet shish but yeah um this is a high table and above so nobles
monarchs pope and church untouchable to us filthy disgusting leprosy infected no peasants okay okay
the pope above the monarch what do you mean the church is above the state hmm oh we have uh
thank you for putting your hand excuse me is first by it's first dream by the way is learning
this okay for the channel or is this what monetization oh what oh no you can learn what you want
i ain't here for the money i'm here for the education you're getting educated against your
pop up okay so that is how it used to be you used to get shanked back in the day you'd be
randomly getting stabbed minding your own business so in exchange for safety on someone's land
you would do all the work reap hardly any benefit so this is a really shitty disgusting
version of capitalism unfortunately capitalism kind of popped off today but i do want to note
why did feudalism fail does any refling have any idea or inclination why feudalism failed
and became old and became outdated that out no longer reflected the society that the world
was in hmm can any remember there's no wrong answers it's okay if you actually don't know
you are more than welcome to suggest a reason why you think feudalism uh was timed out in the 15th
century um hmm i spelled capitalism wrong damn straight i did there must be always
oh thank you we've got corruption and oh okay okay nobility industrial revolution very good
french people i like it i like it because of fast travel we're getting there trade yet rise of
trade the black plague that did really mess up europe that's a different i did not put that in this
lecture because of the rise of the merchant class now what has been identified was the
decline of knights and castles because knights were such a prolific enemy to your life they were
such a danger to your life and kind of having knights to order around to execute willy nilly
people left and right but because of the falling of castles of kingdoms of locations the decline
people started to say hold on a minute i can go do all of this myself and reap a heck of a lot more
than what you're willing to give me so uh it did fail so i have hope all i'm saying is that between
the ninth and the fifth oh did i say the eighth it's the ninth century sorry between the ninth and
the 15th century six hundred years give or take a new form i'm feeling sick can i go to the nurse
okay you can go to the nurse take the whole pass okay but come back with it when you're finished
okay next stage boom topic four since we were looking at a pyramid earlier okay
since we're looking at a pyramid we're gonna move on to big boy maslow's hierarchy of needs let's
okay as you can see i'm hiding up my emote that's behind me right now but we're looking at
maslow's hierarchy of needs now have you ever felt kaka before okay have you ever felt like you do
not belong are the brain worms just winning as these are the questions i have for you stop
don't take your medicine just yet okay don't take your medicine just yet
let's get to the bottom huh or the pyramid okay so you can reach the top
uh uh uh so let us come up with a problem together and find the solution let's find the solution
together to a problem a hypothetical problem so we're gonna take a little little dive into
maslow's hierarchy of needs boom all right refling take it away problem strongy i can't
ink anymore something's wrong and my lust is gone well we have found our problem worry not
i will have you touching yourself in no time let's try out the pyramid method to this thing now don't
throw up in my class go it's vomiting face now right go vomiting face thanks brine go i will
read at the end okay so we have maslow's hierarchy of needs here okay we have psychological uh
psychophysiological needs hey we got there in the end i'll take that we have safety needs
belonging self-esteem and then self-actualization okay so if you cannot ink we're gonna take this
problem physiological needs so this is your physical stuff you need your to achieve homeostasis
homeostasis is when your body is maintaining yourself fine it feels good it's happy things
are good okay so what aren't we achieving together what needs to change dany to tuck you into bed
for rest have you rested that is my question for you do i need to feed you are you hungry okay it's
first thing in the morning and you're uh getting educated against your will okay um what do you say
but oh thank you for putting your hand up but mummy maslow's hierarchy needs have been showed to be
overly simplistic and not no i don't want to hear it okay i don't want to hear i like maslow i really
like maslow okay do i need to feed you could i could bring you a toothbrush if you didn't brush your
teeth in bed i'm not gonna judge no no problem with me i just want your needs to be met because if
your needs are met in big old maslow a big abraham maslow said if you have met all your homeostasis
needs we get to move up a tier okay we get to move up to your safety needs security safety okay so
security can come in a form of different ways okay so i have are you able to socialize well with who
you like hold on i'm gonna have to move my big old head where's my moose oh sorry my cursors
having a hold on let me move myself i'm in the way i'll sit on the i'll just camp down here okay
sorry i'm i'm camping in chat um are you able to socialize well with who you like maybe can you
give your family member a quick call even if you even if you have absolutely nothing new to say under
the sun guess what neither did they they have nothing new under the sun to talk about either
it's just a five minute phone call just because you don't have news refland doesn't mean they don't
do you feel secure in what you're doing that could be related to your job that could be related to
memeing around try and be kind to yourself okay because that is how we achieve uh safety needs
okay security is related to socialization as well okay so don't be don't be too worried don't be too
worried okay now there's one thing being secure in your social relationships and then if we have
done that we get to unlock belonging and needs belongingness and love and needs okay intimate
relationships friendships community okay this is where we're getting really this is where we're
starting to be like we need this okay so i hope you feel as accepted as you can be here okay
okay i am dumb i'm silly i don't understand what's going on in the world you guys have accepted me
without a shadow of a doubt i could have easily been rejected you guys have accepted me i hope
i extend the exact same environment back towards you okay um i don't expect you to be perfect
just as you do not expect me to be perfect okay this is the kind of
socialization that enables both the previous tier so the previous safety needs of security
as well as the intimacy of being accepted as a person you don't have to hide that
you're on the spectrum you don't have to mask you don't have to do anything you can put the most
cringeyest message in the world out there and i will giggle and be like hee hee whatever you're on
about that can you copy no you can't copy off someone okay so if you feel secure you have
belongingness in a community you you feel loved you feel all this good stuff okay then you can
move on to the next tier which is esteem needs prestige and feeling of accomplishment okay
so this is this one is uh a bit more difficult to achieve because not everyone can do it hell even
i'm not really getting there but we're working on it we're getting there do you feel like you are
getting life xp at the moment that is what if you are not that's what's preventing you from being
unable to ink that's it that's the answer um so do you feel like you're getting life xp xp
how would we get you some even if it's super small amount of xp you could learn a new skill
you could investigate a topic that you're interested in and gain new knowledge um working with others
can thrust you into so much easy xp literally the minecraft xp on the floor if you go work in a
coffee shop just picking up all that minecraft xp on the floor okay um working with others or
putting yourself in a situation where you can enable others too to achieve what they need to do
okay um this sounds really silly but you can how your mum does all the dishes
unload the dishwasher once okay she'll be she'll be shocked and in a good way not in a bad way
but just you have enabled your mum one less thing she has to think about in the household okay
these are just the other thing okay and then um you can also enable you can be the secret hero
that doesn't get acknowledged in the credits of the movie but deep down you know it was your
refling that these things can give you life xp that is what gives you self-esteem well it says
esteem needs they don't necessarily mean self-esteem but esteem is quite a big social you need to be
confident in yourself to you know be able to put yourself out there get confident do things okay
so oh i've got a question but if the problem is the fact that you have nothing more to get from
one of your passions you just went so deep there's nothing left um so you have created then in that
scenario um pathways or positivity you have ease of pathways in your head when it comes to nostalgia
in that particular topic just means you have to find something new are you telling me little
reefland in this whole wide world you can um think of one thing to get educated in okay now if you
have a completed esteem needs self-actualization you can beat your shmeat right now if you're at
this stage of self-actualization ink for me after this stream look at the comic that's on my alt account
look at you taking over you can do whatever you want whatever you say i'll do and i'll take it
off so just keep laughing there we go we have solved the problem that we came up with
fantastic stuff so that's how mazla works you can use it um if you're ever facing any difficulties
yourself okay can we do it right now no not during my class after class after class but that is an
example of how you can tackle a problem you may or may not be having with mazl's hierarchy of needs
okay so all these if you're at the bottom tier obviously you're blocked off from doing anything
and we just do it like that okay right next boom bones who doesn't love them ladies and gentlemen
boom one skelly boy okay i have another question chat for you are you ready the question is where
is the smallest bone in the body located located question mark is it a the ear is it b the inner
wrist or is it c the inner spine again there are no wrong answers please just have a hoot and holler
i'm not gonna be mean to you if you don't know better because you're getting educated this stream
get educated get educated get educated pop pop pop pop pop there boom there you go
bones will this be part of the test or is the extra credit i don't know yet i don't know yet
we'll find out in a minute achieving one's full potential through the accomplishment thank you
okay let's see what the votes are oh let's see you okay okay look at my little reeflands
floating away you guys are good at this i'm not passing no i have confidence did you know that
like 80 percent of the work is like showing up or something crazy like that depends on how spinless
the motherfucker is what is this sorry boy oh no my hair is covering up oh no there is like there
you go i'll get out of the way there that's what my mean together to keep your keep attention high
during the lecture i did a little thing there you go i'm out of the way now you can see it now
okay but aren't teeth bones not technically not at all no please don't ever say that again
please do not speak for the rest of the class that's horrific okay you guys have voted that
the smallest bone in the body is located in the ear let's find out no wait
hold on did i forget to download uh that's not the correct slide
where is my slide
where is it i didn't download it give me one second one second pause pause the class pause the class
what the fuck is it oh here is i got it oh i missed okay that's where it is sorry sorry i got it
right we're just gonna have to manually hold on hold on hold on hold on pause pause pause i
fucked up i fucked up okay okay missing bone slide look look i'm a teacher okay it's not all
gonna miraculously be correct all the time like relax i can't have it all right where is it slide
alpha boom i'll fuck anyone
boy ta-da okay it's a bit scuffed but you were right it's the ear you did it
it's that ear um so um you're right it's actually three bones together in your ear
um and they are called does anyone know the name oh wait i'll put the name on the slide sorry
i'll put the name on the slide my apologies are you squiddin me right now okay teacher's not ready
i'm leaving right hidden lore about humans it's three bones in your ear canal and together
they're the hammer the anvil and the stirrup okay and it is absolutely disgusting if you think about
that you're just piloting a meat so honestly it's it's pretty gross so don't think about it too much
but um just as a little side note if you want to increase the um you know like calcium inside your
foods milk yogurt cheese um soy products um some leafy greens can do it but you know it's very
dairy products are very friendly on keeping your bones good so if you've not had a wee
a cheeky yogurt in a while okay then um you can absolutely oh wrong one you can absolutely have
a cheeky yogurt once in a while um all right now we move on to the next one i totally didn't spoil
the next slide at all boom this is for men only women go away this one's for men only you men only
men only okay okay okay right reflinem i need your help for this one
um uh for some reason when i copied and pasted this like top secret say stay out this one like
came out really tiny so we did a bit of sph time okay we're pointing and laughing we're pointing
and laughing at it everyone pointing laugh at it you're so tiny um okay look away the one girl
that's present in chat right now i know you're there look away inside your back doors this thing
that begins with a p all right okay and when you hit 50 you need to go to the doctors to make sure
it's okay and to the one oh gee son that's lurking right now that goes for you too okay it's it's
serious so the symptoms if you're ever having any um prostate difficulty is you have trouble urinating
you have a decreased stream flow so normally you're supposed to like piss like a horse okay
if you find any blood or ink uh or you're like hey that's not supposed to be there you're feeling
bone pain you have unexpected weight loss and unexpected fevers if you notice any of these
symptoms please present yourself to the doctor right away okay now i assure you that every person
you interact with if you present to the er with uh troubles with your butt they have already stuck
their fingers in many butts before you will not be the first butt they stick a finger into and they
will not be the last please do not be embarrassed it is serious to take your health serious okay i
literally got my clam inspected because i always have i have tight clams syndrome and you know i got
diagnosed with it and all that blah blah blah yeah guess what it's a little embarrassing i made the
effort to shave for her because i didn't want her to see my hair me all hairy and stuff so i literally
don't be embarrassed look after your health okay and if you tomatoes are an absolute fantastic
thing for you um question why don't you go to the doctor when i can just milk it myself okay
you're done you're done i'm not no more no more no more putting your hand up to say we've clearly
got a class clown on our hands okay don't encourage them wait hold on hold on wait hold on hold on hold
hold on wait let's try that again oh wait what did you say wait let me do it again why didn't you
go to the doctor when i could just milk it myself oh no don't encourage him class do not encourage
him he's gonna he's gonna keep up with the jokes don't encourage him okay right tomatoes i don't
care how you have the tomatoes as long as you have the tomato okay if you can have it in spaghetti
i can't spell it spaghetti spaghetti i don't know uh bruschetta i literally tomato on toast do a
bit of basil and balsamic vinegar i can't remember how you produce it okay no don't laugh don't laugh
okay a tomato pasta bake a ham and tomato toasty tomato sauce i guess with chicken nuggies that's
fine tomato and bacon fry up i perfect absolutely perfect i will get out of the way for this next
one two long didn't read berries also have antioxidant properties which are fantastic for
your prostate health to um red food stops your pee being red okay thank you thank you i know i am
so good at this presentation but it's true so please do consider upping your tomatoes okay
okay any tomato lovers i saw you this weekend running an event called strone's saturday night
clam slam how do i sign up to be a participant yeah do i ask after class no that did not happen
unreal untrue also me who's releasing a freaking foot of teacher audio today after the stream this
is so messed up and oh this topic i'm very passionate about okay how peter jackson made the clutch of
the century and no one knows about it but now you are being knowing about it you are being
knowledge okay you're being knowledge so this is the hobbit in particular this is the hobbit
so big totoro uh toro was originally going to be the director but warner brothers refused to
give a finalized budget causing insane planning issues okay so this was originally going to be
the director but instead is peter jackson thank goodness but in his defense how on earth can you
plan for a movie at the time it was going to be two movies um if you don't even know what you can
afford so peter jackson stepped in what a legend okay from the stress alone of creating the hobbit
i think it was like 299 days to shoot it that doesn't include pre-production and anything
afterwards from stress alone he developed a stomach ulcer and then when he got healthy again
he jumped straight back into why is this man not getting acknowledgement for having insanely hard
working he is okay you thought that was gay but honestly i can see what you mean okay
um he was diagnosed with a perforated ulcer um he lost a serious amount of weight like an unhealthy
amount of weight if you have rapid weight loss that's actually not good for your body it shocks your
homeostasis abilities okay so originally the hobbit was actually going to be two films but quickly
into production um peter jackson and fran walsh realized that they were going to have to far out
an entire third movie overnight they had lost so much sleep so much sleep over this it's insanity
okay and it was the worst budget i will never forgive warner brothers i like such greedy bastards
they had seen how much lord of the rings earned and they went right do the hobbit but here's a
fraction of the fucking budget as if they didn't have the returns of lord of the rings sitting
in their wee book um uh literally i was typing this last night and i started vibrating in my
chair and like i was getting really aggressive with the keyboard and stuff i was raging okay so
peter jackson spent years on the pre-production of lord of the rings okay for the hobbit he had four
months four months pre-production for a trilogy is insane no wonder that poor man developed a
freaking stomach also okay stress in the workplace is real it's it's absolutely horrific what he went
through okay and i just want to say tariel might not be for you in the movie but she's for me and
then i'm spanking you okay i will not take tariel slander don't upset me okay not all characters
have to be lore friendly but i genuinely like her and i think the forbidden love thing is really cute
okay and anyway let's make out before i start crying at the hobbit okay and then i said i would
like to watch the hobbit on boxing day with you if that's okay and then on christmas we're gonna
watch lord of the rings but because this was about the hobbit i didn't really mention lord of the
rings that much but yeah okay let me let me get back into the correct side my lecturing side okay
so you've so you have now learned that peter jackson is a legend thank you i just need the world
to acknowledge how hard that man tries surprise you have a quiz it's a surprise quiz oh you aren't
ready for this one okay you aren't ready for this one i have a questionnaire for you
now please put your name and date at the top we are going to now uh right i'll just wait hold on
let me put on fucking scribbling background ambience okay there we go everyone start taking the test
yep perfect right put your name at the top top of the paper good all right and then today's date
for you it's the 16th for me it's the 17th because i'm in the future baby well it worked i'm surprised
you're about to ace it okay question one how prego can you get her ego in days of the month
i didn't finish that how many days can her ego get pregnant okay write down your answers
all right all right write down your answers fantastic oh wait are we doing it oh wait hold on i'm an
idiot am i an idiot i mean a little bit it's fine okay name three types of i don't wait hold on i'm
doing this wrong i'm doing this wrong hold on pause pause hold the tunes i'm doing this wrong
okay let's try again let's try again are you ready boom okay today no we can fill it out
no we can fill it out right your name you can either be anon or you can either be refling okay
there you go there's your name refling
dot
the today's date right now is no wrong legends 99 underscore date yes please okay you have to do
day month and year because why on earth do you do it the other way around americans what the
fuck are you high on anything technically it's this for me right now i'm in the future i know don't
be alarmed don't be alarmed and i'm refling that's me okay how many days can you get her ego prego
let me let me do a q&a okay question one wait kind of is this even gonna work
okay just drop answers in here is that gonna work can i see what you guys say to me
what the all summary says viewers are reacting to information being project processed in a lecture
they're feeling various of emotions including anxiety are you guys okay what the fuck is a
kilometer honestly all right let's see two days okay fantastic we've got two days question number
name three types of seed dispersal actually not yet not that but yeah name three types of seed
dispersal let's see what you come up with one day a year let me talk one to two we also have one to
two yes i technically would okay wait we're not marking it yet hold on we're not marking it yet
we're not marking it yet i'm getting i'm getting too excited to mark your answers
let's see oh i've got i've got water
well so if i got no i've got winds i've got wind okay okay war wind
and we've got animal that's when you eat it fantastic you've done it okay next question
what is region locked capitalism called huh what's region locked capitalism called
someone's already answered it you're too quick for me let's scroll down a little bit
the animal exploding wind water and it sounds like we did speaking
feudalism fair you i can't spell it
perfect now finish the following name for the work of an a pop for of a popular american
psychologist hierarchy of needs whose hierarchy of needs is the question
truly we do not know yet okay
okay feudalism i probably end up spelling it like that strongy calls his hierarchy of needs
good attempt to be knocked away mazlowe correct mazlowe and then apostrophe it's mazlowe's hierarchy
name one food item that may help strengthen bones you are more than welcome to do that
what kind of food item may strengthen bones at will if you remember your food groups we
know one food group is very nice for our bones someone said azura's milk i'll love it okay azura's
milk at razora's milk he he he he okay this is the first one right let's save it oh wait hold on
wrong one what was that let's see i need to save it first and i don't know what it's going to come
up with if i try and save it so answers one and then we're going to go on the next page and we're
going to answer the second batch of questions if i've done this correctly boom okay name one symptom
you should present yourself and your prostate to the er with okay name one symptom that you
should present yourself and your prostate with to the er okay mommy's milk mommy doesn't have milk
like that i mean technically i do if i have five children um difficulty peeing correct difficult
day if it's a kid all day kid all day peeing or stream or
stream issues and i'm not really into youtube streaming you know or stream issues there fantastic
and then last but not least on a scale of one to ten rank lord of the rings in the hobbit franchise
ten being the best one being kaka and there's only one answer to this one again all these answers
there's only one you know kind of thing you can do um seven point six nine well you're getting timed
out okay ten no you're supposed to write there's only one answer okay in the q and a you guys are
answering ten but you guys are trolling on stream how dare you ten and then a big smiley face because
i love it so much okay please remember to write your name on the other side of the paper and hand
it to me when finished please sit down and read a bit quietly until everyone has finished filling
in their answers just because you've finished filling in your answer already does not mean that
your classmates have already finished as quick as you even though we did it together as a class
okay is that is that everyone done okay right let's make sure i save this
okay save as answers to okay let's go over your answers let's see if you got everything right
is my question um right let's see today's date
it is the 17th for me you're so right refling and you remembered your name well done that's two
points how prego can you get her ego in a day today you remember fantastic refling you're doing great
okay name three types of squids you got water white what does that mean no i know i'll deal with
all the problems at the end we've got water well done we've got wind well done animals fantastic
but do you remember the other two maybe you don't remember the other two and there were the two others
are explosion and gravity gravity okay region locked capitalism is called feudalism
fantastic you guys are ace in this holy holy moly um finish the following name for the work of a
popular american psychologist mazo and name one food item that may help strengthen your bones milk
yay doesn't matter if it comes from from the booba of uh of uh sheepsters uh sheepsters no uh from
azura okay and then answers number two you should present yourself to er or any medical help if you
have difficulty peeing or stream issues not related to youtuber twitch streaming uh a different kind
and then of course 10 out of 10 for with this effect or gpa well i mean you aced it how do i
think i think it's like an a and then i circle it oh no i want black please
i don't know why it's like that a plus you did every fling
yay you got an applause thank you everyone what did you think right school's over boom
you did it what do well do you feel more educated now do you feel smarter even though i have a 20
second delay on like an asshole give us an s the straw near proves you did it or an a star in europe
oh i don't an a star you have now received the qualification straw knees special interest part
one if you guys enjoyed this then we'll do straw knees special interest part two
and i won't mess it up and have a freaking 20 second delay on i have no idea why it's
be followed to that i always have on low latency but uh i guess youtube doesn't like me today
this stream was actually really good you like it did your brain get new wrinkles my brain has
three more wrinkles i messed up the day that's okay i'm in the future so technically it's not that
bad we got skilled gonna frame my strong to some degree on the wall i feel somewhat more knowledgeable
stroney if you look up the medical journal topic of pregnancy it says the window of ovulation
why are you saying it's too so i'm saying it's too because the reason why it's so extended is
will you accept pictures of our notes and quiz in marshmallow yeah wait did you actually do it
the reason why i say is two days is because the actual amount of time the egg can be fertilized
is is such a tiny tiny window so you know when couples are like oh we've been trying to get
pregnant for ages it's because you literally need to plop plop plop plop plop every single day if
you're serious about wanting a wane okay like if you're actually wanting a baby then you need to
plop every single day like days straight um but you know if by the third month you've plopped
every single day and no child has been born um all right sorry no um egg has taken you know
probably one partner's got infertility it's really not a big deal i don't know people make a really
big deal about that but oh someone said the bit about tomatoes and the prostate was good stuff
you learned something new yes it's because of the antioxidants um it really helps like do something
to your balls and stuff no your prostate which is i don't know i'm sure okay can i test out with you
not yet gen two is not in the oven yet okay i'll tell you when gen two is in the oven
you seem to have a lot of research on getting pregnant i find it really fascinating um
i like i looked into IVF and all of that no for me i'm not birthing a child anytime soon i can
assure you that much these nips stay pink in this corner um but it's um infertility is a very
so i need to choose my words carefully because i don't want to offend anyone
um some people see that not having children is the be all end all of their life and it can
completely decimate any uh semblance of confidence of self-esteem of um ego now it's
actually good to have ego believe it or not and it is really fascinating stuff the psychology
that plays in being told that you're infertile or you can't spawn your own offspring uh some
people that me if i was told that i cannot bear children reeflings that ASMR boost is happening
i don't give a fuck no risk are you joking like i don't give a fuck um micro plastics have messed
up or reproductive i would not be surprised if that is why there's a lot of people facing um
a lot of reproductive things but that's a conspiracy theory for another day because just
remember if you ever think the government wouldn't do that they already knew about micro plastics
years ago they hid it from the people and this is the twelfth because i have found the research on it
uh
do you guys like your new emotes by the way did you see them did you see the new emotes
right i will drop i will end the q and a confirm wow okay now show me the emotes
show me the emotes i already have like four more emotes slots i don't know what to get but i have
all my emotes i like this one yeah you like the meme even though freaking licking is ban
silly silly youtube ban in it
love the new emotes yeah yes you like my burp one they're pretty cool i love the hug
emotes this is so perfect i'm so happy shebe's emotes are about to be here and so are zura's
we just need a fix on two of zura's emotes and then two of my favorites oh yeah the png heart
that wasn't a png is your favorite emote yeah i bet it is okay let me open up stream elements
suck in thank tips and donos i do apologize for getting ignoring you in the middle of class but
look i was trying to do a class okay i was trying to educate the masses okay let me just check
why did why did i just get smaller don't be shy don't be shy put them on okay let me just check
one hour ago thank you chair just hit a personal best deadlift to this thank you moment oh you're
more than welcome gift it's wait where's your name are you squidding me right now i don't see your
name in that gift hi strony i'm so sorry if i shouldn't ask this here but i didn't know where to ask
yeah yeah in wondering when y'all may be on fensley slash the price to watch slash support our roshi
will price depend on the creator slash stream just want to know how much my wallet will
yes there's been a bit of an update smiley face it's been a bit of an update about that right
let me get through the super chats i will answer that one last okay uh chair just hit a personal
best deadlifts is thank you mom you're more than welcome thank you for getting educated pop up up
boy said i'm feeling sick can i go to the nurse yes you most certainly can i'm sorry you're not
feeling good thank you boy for the tip broly legend just threw up in the middle of the class this is
i feel like i have to throw up and then broly legend says teacher's not ready i'm leaving i was ready
i made one little oopsie whoopsie i forgot to download one PowerPoint play okay tiny spainy
i saw you this weekend running an event called strony saturday night clam slam how do i sign up
do i do after class honestly that sounds like a really good game show like you know how like
vtubers come up with game shows i feel like um like oh come on to strony saturday night clam slam
and we talk about like i don't know being a vtuber and stuff broly legend oh you put your
name and date on the paper correctly date yes please oh get it okay that's actually not that
bad good super chat good super chat boy says i peed white what does that mean you're not supposed
to pee wait in the middle of class like i'm the meaner i'm glad i fit i solved the mazl's hierarchy
in each problem reefling will you accept pictures of our notes in the quiz thank you reefling for
the tip yes you can marshmallow it and then annom nom said hi strony i didn't know if you know you
can ask away for bandsley okay so i come to a terrible realization um so the girl i violor
are not taking a cut from bandsley um that was an oversight by me um because originally i said it
was going to be free access but i we violor do not dictate what if the girl streams on fansley or
not so they keep a hundred percent of the earnings so whatever price range is what they put on but
they earn a hundred percent we do not take any of a cut so i don't know what they're going to charge
i don't know what they're going to do it's on an individual basis i apologize but it's just how it's
going to be um it was a massive oversight for me to say that it was going to be free to view
because i don't like that's their stuff that's what they do the contract doesn't stipulate for the
girls to stream on uh bandsley or any kind of website like that so they get a hundred percent
of their earnings um as always pretty much um so i do apologize um for my previous misinformation
i spoke before i actually thought about the situation but the girls are getting access on
august 1st i don't know what they're doing but as long as they have fun that's the main thing um
yes the girls have also come out with gamer subs um we are all getting sent pure packages so i don't
know if they're going to be a few handcam streams but i plan on doing a handcam stream um and gamer
subs were actually very kind and said that i'm allowed to say out loud that if um there's a
certain amount of sales number reached then vealer can potentially get a cup or a waifu
shaker baker maker producers um uh so yeah if you drink it in general or you ever wanted to try it
out please don't be afraid to use anyone's code at any point um hundred percent of the earnings
go to them again vealer does not take a cut um it is a hundred percent to them um and yeah uh that
was like a really big news we were sitting on that news for a while um i can finally talk about it
and i'm so happy for the girls like they got the codes and um she be uh she was so happy um thank
you stroney also for next time world would be the best place to ask you like this oh you can just
ask on fanzly for free i'm so sorry thank you for the tip you don't have to give me money i always
say that don't have to give me money to ask any questions i'll open up marshmallow now okay
i'll put marshmallow here's my answers no way you actually did it hold on
oh my god you actually did it oh can i show it oh i don't know if i'm allowed to show it
i don't know oh you didn't say if i can share it but i see a reefling actually filled out the
questions we need a AC waifu shaker cup i'm not sure gamer stuff is going to make it through the
custom uh uh on the list glad you guys are growing so fast she always wanted to do this being
sponsored is a big step yes no that's what i was trying to say before i got distracted sorry
um thank you again and on for the tip that was very kind of you uh she be was like i've always
wanted to like say that i've been sponsored i'm like oh well wake up because you got it um from
your old your hardworking stuff and i'm so happy for the girls actually speaking of she be she's
almost at 10k subs which i'm oh my god oh my god now you guys won't believe it but we actually got
called again a little bit but she be cotton bum is 500 subscribers off of 10k subs so if you would love
to be uh an adorable and the link in the description below is she be i think i'm able to redirect
into her today as well which is fantastic um because i don't always get the opportunity
because she's a busy bee she was at the vet with her putters the other day
unless she be doesn't have her wait room up hold on a minute does she be no stream today
yeah i see who's talking about getting called again get sponsored get sponsored get affiliate get
affiliate i see got called those twice yeah i got called a little bit but i managed to bounce back
feels good man um but yes i could have sworn she be was streaming today i'm just i'm clearly
schizophrenic i'm losing it because what am i going on
i she's always going live is it not off is she not put it up
monday members watch along with yesterday so she's just not put up her collab with mersey yet
oh she isn't doing it oh okay oh that's unfortunate um oh no she is doing it isn't she doing it
yeah i thought so oh it's in five hours okay well i definitely can't redirect into that
is any up before that i don't there's no one online right now that can redirect into did you
guys like my newest short wait i'm gonna link it hold on you're all getting forced to watch my
new short because people asked me this a lot so if you didn't know i was a pre-selected talent
blah blah blah you know the you know the drill and they were like why didn't you voice the trailer
and i'm like why didn't i voice the trailer are you being so for real right now why didn't i the
scottish one voice the trailer to veal or are you joking so have a little swatch yeah i mean he's
doing poppy's playtime well i might just redirect into that i mean you're gonna be waiting a lot
you're gonna be waiting a hot second for that but um i'll let you i don't know if you've seen
that short but uh yeah i already watched and commented oh i need to improve comments i've
not proved them yet this morning um i as there is everyone now has two audios up on patreon
which is correct for this point in time i am adding mine after my nap because you guys are so kind to
me um i'll redirect into emers's frickin room and yes we emmy emmy emmy yeah emmy yeah
drank em em em yeah she's playing poppy's playtime
spooky scary skeletons and shivers down your spine
what do you mean that would have been amazing scottish trailer peak
of want a fresh start in your vtubering career
receive a spectacular live 2d model it's so cringe it's so cringe the face of veal or
should i voice that i'm not the face of veal or emmy is i'm actually glad someone's ahead of me
i'm fucking celebrate i'm like oh come on get ahead of me thank you for the stream glee claras
yeah you have to go don't worry it's okay i'm i'm wrapping up class as well i'm wrapping it up
yes the short was funny exactly the scottish trailer would have been pair are you joking
you want a full version of it but it's so rubbish refreshing those r's it would be cinema
oh 80 20 split and so much more we offer at the hour
did you know go ahead and get pop up up check maro and check maro maro check a maro trigger
i was gonna ask a question but i forgot i was gonna say that hypnosis is called yes um uh my hypnosis
is gonna start up once my dad goes home um the last like six days of july uh you're getting
absolutely plopped out the wazoo i'm sorry i'm saying it now you're getting plopped out the wazoo
there's gonna be so many twitter audios i don't even care it's the truth
um mommy just for me can you say purple burglar alarm so i can say it if i don't have my harsh
accent on so purple burglar alarm i can say it but if i put my harsher accent on purple burglar alarm
i get stuck my tongue gets stuck at the top of my mouth i don't know if it gets stuck for you guys
but uh yeah harsh accent purple purple la la la la la la la la i sound like i sound like stitch
from lilo instead hi purple burglar alarm um hi starry i've been so happy since veal
our debut i'm so glad meflin every day's been full of fun and a good time i love you so much i think
um if ever went to a convention to meet you i'd probably spell my spaghetti oh don't be silly
i'm printing out a thing where you can touch it if you want like a hug or a high five if you're
too scared to talk to me don't worry i'll get you covered i have so much respect for you you're
worth a thick in your vision i can't help but kneel no rise my king you kneel to no one you kneel
to no one you never kneel to me okay you are we are an equal playing field i love what you
need to talk about games you've played as a kid especially because i've played some of them too
ah yeah you've truly special and worthy of the title camo cameo she's dumb i love her tight
knit community and i think we all know there's a part of you that shines like gold yeah yeah you
like something about me yeah i bet you do i bet you do how goes the evil siren plot uh we remember
it starts up in a week okay it starts up all over in a week again i'm gonna do real hypnosis for
real for real okay i promise i'll do hypnosis for real for real i have so many stuff to write
i just want to resend this story from a few days ago but i had a pretty bad nightmare a few days
back and i woke up and during it woke up enduring sleep paralysis it's common but i heard your voice
reassuring me i was able to get my phone and listen to a smart able to calm down oh no you had a
nightmare i don't think nightmare and thingy is the same but i'm glad you feel better replaying
you need to know one what if we need to get enough okay i'll allow it for that that's a load
well but you don't have to kneel to me i'm just me imagine if i spoke to you like that
only needing
um i just want yeah
who said this 35 minutes ago you know i like you irish accent speaking cuttlefish irish
irish
irish it's a 50 50 between scotland and ireland okay irish
i'm scottish i'm a scottish cuttlefish cuttlefish are on the coast of scotland in japan
i'm scottish you know big william wallace freedom what other things are scotland no
haggis deep fried mars mars kills i'm scottish i'm not irish if i was irish i'd sound like this
dear father who art in heaven how old be thy name today we gather because of this
refling that we're gonna crucify together for thinking that i was irish first we place him on
the pyre because we're gonna burn this motherfucker alive until he's tokyaki
that's me i'm bruce yes i'm i'm bruce okay but i'll forgive you for your transgression against
me i'm at work typing this right now so i'll ink for you when i leave it's only fear since you give
me multiple oh you got stiffy at work have a good day i'll take care of myself okay you're all
forgiven you're forgiven because you're listening at work and then you got a bone bone i forgive you
ye what's the gender ratio of your viewers i will show you i do not keep secrets when it comes
to content creation i will show you uh analytics analytics and what audience
analytics audience hold on hold on it's loading
my audience ratio is male 98.2 female 1.5 and 0.3 for user unspecified
um i know some v-tubers are like happy to have like a ratio of female but it does not
bother me at all uh i'll never be around the bush uh i cater to a male audience a male audience
it's fine for me yes i catered to male audience i have absolutely no shame no qualms no anything
about it no nothing negative some v-tubers are like oh my god i have like expended female viewers
i don't give a fuck give me your tentacle and ink right now
um
hehehehe it's me i'm the 1.5% truly i'm like convinced that like the other female percent
is just other v-tubers checking me out being like damn she crazy
a proud 1.5 female oh that's wonderful how you doing any refling can have a tentacle male or
female true true who is walrus the pokemon no william walrus oh dan needs to do a scottish
education stream do you not know who william walrus is i think i need to do it hold on let
me write this down i think we need a scottish education stream unironically did you guys
enjoy this stream if you did i will legit make a scottish education stream what do you mean we
sent for real for real blessing all the other v-tubers isn't that male gibson no that's brave
hard i've not even seen brave heart how about we do a scottish education stream and then we end
it with a brave heart watch along because i've never actually seen brave heart i'm not kidding um
it's like the film that represents scotland and i've yet to see it i've yet to see it so how about
we do that we do scottish education stream we fill out our questionnaire and then we watch brave
heart together that sounds like fun yeah i think so okay teachers anything yeah did you enjoy that
i'm glad i was just putting it together like spanking my keyboard oh sorry i called you irish no
reefling it's fine i'm teasing i'm teasing it's fine it's either irish or scottish so i'm glad
it's okay i will work on a scottish education stream at some point um i think next week i've
actually fully planned out what we're doing next week if not then you might see the scottish
stream a lot earlier than expected oh eternity thank you for the 20 gifted memberships i appreciate
and congrats to those who cut it with your face wow we're like so close to unlocking any emotes
slot oh my god meryl got a membership oh enjoy the emotes hehehe scourish honestly love you mommy
love you too reefling okay uh unfortunately i have terrible news reeflings i'm gonna have to go back
to sleep and you'll have good sleep again no no no no good sleep i have very bad sleep
human reproduction education stream when i was gonna buy a microphone that can put inside myself
if that's what you want i will do what other vtubers do not you ever watched outlocking
uh uh yeah first gifted sub ever and you cut it with your face
okay i'm not gonna stall because i need to rest actually i do have good news about papakut also
my dad's feeling a lot better we went on a walk yesterday and it was lovely like we were just
having a walk but i'm really worried about getting uh ill from him because i don't want to stream ill
i'm gonna be midi i don't want to stream ill but my dad feels better and i feel a lot less
stressed now that he feels better because he really wasn't well i had to go to the pharmacy for him and
all that jazz um but yeah i was gonna ask a question but forgot so i'm gonna say that that
hypothesis is paul mazo's hierarchy of needs um
hi stroney would you be willing to watch something sad as long as you knew it was
beforehand there's an anime called violet evergarden it's beautiful but satir do you want me to cry
i will cry is that what you're saying me good to hear he's feeling better stroney plus the idea
sleepy cuddles so you can feel cuddled oh that's adorable i want a plushie so badly
and then i want a refling plushie so i can do ASMR with you on stream and i can touch your
leg on stream uh hi mommy hi refling i can't believe i was lucky enough to find you and the
rest of you i'm glad you're at your scottish accent and rage is very cute and funny i've only raged
a few times so if you've heard the rage you've definitely been lucky to catch it you're such a
little tease and i can't help but want to ink to you in your audio yeah you want to ink to my audio
i can't decide whether i want to take i want to let you take control of me or i take control
and ink inside your clown i'm in love with the cultish oh yeah you're in love with the cult of
it you want to ink inside me and you want me to have control why not both
okay no more stalling i do need to rest um i'll hold you while you cry
okay no more stalling thank you so so much i'm so sorry about it being a shorter stream
i am facing some things behind the scenes as always i'm always doing something behind the scenes
i'm always cooking but everyone on patreon has two audios up except me but i'm putting mine up after
the stream uh and it's the teacher one so uh on patreon but i'm going to have a rest because
i never slept properly i slept four hours before the stream first okay oh i'm surviving i'm still
standing better than i ever did but yes i'll see you goofy cool boys tomorrow what are we doing
tomorrow i don't even know i'm still standing better than i ever did looking like a true sir
we're putting supermarkets simulator apparently it's infinite but i'm gonna watch someone play it
i don't know if we'll swap it out for something else i don't know we'll find out i've never played
it before but it seems to have vtubers in a grip because every time i look around there's a freaking
vtuber playing it and i'm like damn is the game like good well we're gonna find out together tomorrow
are you ready adrenaline is pumping okay wasn't it ring fit is it ring fit there's i need to change
the dates on some of the streams that wouldn't let me put up the rest of them anyway i am going to
redirect into emi's poppy's playtime so you are going to be in dead silence for like three hours
if you stick around for that but you can just leave it in the background i mean geez why not why
not um but thank you so so much for doing that and listening to me talk about subjects i'm
interested in i know they were probably like really random and scattered and stuff but i really like
so i give you a big kiss you're gonna be okay on your own i'll see you tomorrow yeah same time
same time tomorrow
oh someone said to get a bone bone every time i kiss them
okay bye bye refilling i'll see you tomorrow okay
love you
i don't i don't know how hard i can suck your face
okay i did it okay we get educated another time but thank you that was really fun i really
enjoyed myself doing that stream okay i love you everything